اهلا بكم مشاهدينا طالب الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس بتشكيل لجنه تحقيق دوليه تختص
بجرائم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد
الفلسطينيين وكشف عباس عن التحضير لمجموعه
خطوات لوقف العدوان الاسرائيلي لكن
مستشاره السياسي استبعد اللجوء الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه في الوقت الراهن نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين الى اي حد
جاء رد فعل القياده الفلسطينيه متناسبا مع
مستوى الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه الاخيره ضد
الفلسطينيين وما الخطوات التي يجب ان
تتخذها السلطه لحمايه مواطنيها من
انتهاكات الاحتلال المتصاعده
بحقهم
اذا في خضم تصعيد اسرائيلي متواصل ضد
الفلسطينيين في الفتره الاخيره وفي سياق
انتهاكات مستمره بحقهم قررت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه العوده الى سياسه هدم المنازل
التي كانت قد اتبعتها لدى انطلاق
الانتفاضه الثانيه وقبل ذلك بعيد بد
الاحتلال اجراء رافقه قمع مفرط ضد
الاحتجاجات التي تفجرت بقوه عقب قتل
مستوطنين الفتى الفلسطيني محمد ابو خضير
الذي استشهد حرقا يوم الثلاثاء الماضي
وازاء كل هذه التطورات اصدرت السلطه
الفلسطينيه تصريحات ومطالبات تفاوتت وجهات
النظر حول مناسبتها لمستوى ما وقع على
الارض تتصاعد الاحداث في فلسطين على خلفيه
جريمه قتل الفتى محمد ابو خدير حرقا يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي وتتواصل المواجهات بين
الشرطه الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيين وتحدث
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني عن اعتقال العشرات
خلال اليومين الماضيين بينهم مصابون ونحو
نصفهم قاصرون لا لا تطورات الاحداث وضعت
عده علامات استفهام بشان خيارات السلطه
الفلسطينيه والرئيس محمود عباس الذي طالب
في رساله بعث بها للامين العام للامم
المتحده بتشكيل لجنه تحقيق دوليه تختص
بجرائم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق
الفلسطينيين واشار عباس الى ان القياده
الفلسطينيه تحضر مجموعه خطوه لم يحددها
لكنه قال ان هدفها وقف العدوان الاسرائيلي
وكان مستشاره السياسي نمر حماد اكد في
حديث للجزيره ان السلطه الفلسطينيه بصدد
تفعيل مختلف الاتفاقيات الدوليه من اجل
تحقيق الحمايه الدوليه للشعب الفلسطيني
الواقع تحت الاحتلال لكنه قال ان السلطه
لن تلجا الى محكمه الجنايات الدوليه في
الوقت الراهن ثابت ان اسرائيل تنتهك مختلف
الاتفاقات الدوليه بما هو معروف وممارس
يوميا لكن الثابت ايضا ان القوى الدوليه
طالما تعاملت مع القضيه الفلسطينيه
وتطوراتها اما
بمكالمتك استراتيجياتها
ومصالحها جريمه قتل الفتاه محمد ابو خضير
مثلا وجدت تنديدا دوليا واسعا لكن واشنطن
ركزت على جانب اخر من القضيه اعربت عن
قلقها جراء تعرض ابن عم القتيل الذي يحمل
الجنسيه الامريكيه للضرب المبرح من قبل
الشرطه الاسرائيليه ودعت للتحقيق في ذلك
حتى عندما اعتقلت الشرطه الاسرائيليه
مشتبهين بالضلوع في قتل محمد ابو خدير
اصرت على ان خلفيه الجريمه قوميه وهو
تعبير مخفف تستخدمه سلطات الاحتلال لوصف
الاحداث التي تقع على خلفيه الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي الفلسطينيون هم
وحدهم المعنيون بالتفكير في الوسائل
المناسبه لحمايه انفسهم والسؤال المتعلق
بكيفيه ذلك ودور القياده الفلسطينيه فيه
يظل مطروحا حتى اشعار اخر
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من رام
الله عبد الله عبد الله رئيس اللجنه
السياسيه في المجلس التشريع الفلسطيني ومن
رام الله ايضا مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن
واشنطن الكاتب الصحفي سعيد عراقات وابدا
معك سيد البرغوتي هل ترى رد فعل السلطه
الفلسطينيه مناسبا مع او متناسبا مع
ممارسات
الاحتلال اعتقد انه ما من مبالغه في الق
بعد ان راينا هذه الهبه الشعبيه الرائعه
في القدس وفي كل انحاء
فلسطين لا مبالغه في القول ان الشعب متقدم
على قيادته واعتقد ان ردود الافعال حتى
الان كانت متاخره وغير كافيه ولا بد من
خطوات اكثر جذريه ويجب ان تتخذ فورا وعلى
راسها ضروره التوجه الفوري الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه لمحاكمه اسرائيل على
جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها لم يعد هناك سبب
او مبرر الاستمرار في التردد بهذا الشان
الامر الثاني المطلوب والذي يالب به الناس
وهذا اهم شي الان في تنظيم النضال الوي هو
تتشكل قياده ونيه موحده للشعب الفلسطيني
توضع كفه الخفات جان وان تتشكل لجان
الحمايه والقياده النيه الموحده في احياء
ومنا الضفه الربيه لحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني
من ارهاب مدوج يقوم به المستوطنون
الاسرائيليون واضا جيش الاحتلال معا وبشكل
متكامل ايضا نحن بحاجه الى مراجعه
استراتيجيه جذريه انا اعتقد ان الامر ليس
خطوات تكتيكيه هنا وهناك المساله نحن نعيش
منعطف استراتيجي بمعنى ان كل مرحله اسلو
انتهت قضت عليها اسرائيل لم يبقى منها شي
اسيتان نقطتان اساسيتان سيد البروتي اشرت
اليهما سيد عبد الله لماذا ليس هناك
استعداد حالي وفوري للذهاب الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه
حتى لو ذهبنا الى محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
ستجد من يقول لماذا لن نعمل كذا ونعمل كذا
هذه هذه مجزره جديده ترتكب في نازيه جديده
تقوم بها الحكومه الاسرائيليه ب شعبها
الثلاثه الحكومه من جهه الجيش من جهه
ثانيه المستوطنون من جهه ثالثه هذه
الهجمه الشامله تواجه على اكثر من صعيد
على الصعيد الداخلي هنالك الهبه الشعبيه
كيف نقول انه ليس هنالك من فارق بين
القياده والشعب القياده هي الشعب والشعب
هي القياده نحن جسم واحد جميعنا نقع تحت
الاحتلال وجميعنا نتق لكنك لم تجبني على
موضوع محكمه الجنايات الدوليه لكن لجني
على هذ
واحده
يا انا بقول لك محكمه الجنايه الدوليه في
لها اكثر من اجراء
هذا الاجراء الطلب الفلسطيني موجود لدى
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه من العام 2009 وفي
ذلك الوقت انا كنت على برنامج على قناتكم
على
فضائيتين احنا في هذه المرحله حقيقه لا
نقبل ان يوجه لنا اصبع اتهام احنا نريد
تضافر جهود معنا مش اتهام الان هذه
المعركه في نازيه جديده ما الفرق بين
الحرق في افران الغاز والحرق في الهواء
الطلق في تلال دير ياسين هذه ليس فقط
مسؤوليه الفلسطينيين وليس مسؤوليه العرب
وحدهم هذه مسؤوليه المجتمع الدولي اللي ما
زال حتى الان يذرف الدمع على ما جرى قبل
عاما
تتحم
جميعا سيد عريقات هل ترى مبررا لان تكون
ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه الرسميه فقط في
اطار الدعوه الى الهبه
الشعبيه لا انا اعتقد ان من يعتقد من يقول
انه ليس هناك خيارات امام الشعب الفلسطيني
في مقاومه ودحر الاحتلال هو غلطان جدا
وانا اتفق مع ما قاله الدكتور مصطفى حقيقه
ان الشعب متقدم على قيادته بمعنى ان هناك
الخيارات الكثيره بامكان القياده
الفلسطينيه ان تضعها قيد تنفيذ فورا الان
اولها اولا السعي من ان من اجل ان تكون
بدل ان تكون سلطه وطنيه فلسطينيه يجب ان
تكون دوله تحت الاحتلال وتبدا العمليه
الاليه من اجل تفعيل ذلك ومن
ثم تفتح تفسح المجال امام نفسها كي تعمل
عبر الاطر الدوليه لتذهب الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه لانه حقيقه ليست بهذه
السهوله القول باننا سنذهب الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه لا يعني ان بامكانك ان
تفعل ذلك هناك العديد من القضايا التي يجب
ان تضعها العديد من الخطوات التي يجب ان
تتخذها وسي عقات ما الذي يمنع السلطه
فعليا
وسياسيا من القيام بهذه الخطوات ما الذي
يمنعها انا اعتقد انه ما يمنع السلطه هو
حقيقه الاتفاقات التي ابرمتها على السلطه
ان ان ان تعود الى الخلف وتقول ان هذه
الاتفاقات المبرمه التي تصر عليها
الولايات المتحده وتصر عليها اسرائيل هي
لم تعد اي ذات فعاليه هي هي باطله حقيقه
لانه الاستيطان استمر العدوان يستمر اي
ال الوعود بقيام دوله فلسطينيه خلال فترات
محدده خلال اربع سنوات وخمس سنوات و و
خارطه الطريق وغيرها كلها اصبحت باطله اذا
علينا العوده والتراجع عن هذه الاتفاقات
خاصه التنسيق الامني من ناحيه ومن ثم
العمل من اجل ان يكون هناك مصالحه وطنيه
ميدانيه ليس فقط بالكلام وليس فقط عبر
وزاره ولكن حقيقه في مواجهه هذا الاحتلال
المجرم الشرس دكتور البرغوتي موضوع محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه موضوع على الطاوله
والطلب موجود وبالتالي كلما قامت بشيء
السلطه سنسمع من يقول لماذا لا تفعل كذا
ولا تفعل كذا وبالتالي المطالبات
ستستمر اولا دع اوضح نحن كلنا ابناء شعب
واحد وابناء حركه وطنيه واحده وعندما
نختلف في الراي ونبض راينا هذا لا يعني
توجيه اتهامات ويجب ان يكون هناك سعه صدر
لتقبل الراي الاخر خاصه انه الراي الاخر
وفي هذه الحاله راينا اثبت اثبتت الحياه
صحته سواء كان فيما يتعلق بالمقاومه
الشعبيه او بحركه المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات
على اسرائيل او بالتوجه لمؤسسات الدوليه
او المطالبه بالاعتراف في فلسطين كدوله
يعني السجل واضح لذلك انا اعتقد الافضل
الاصغاء لما نقترحه بدل الحديث عن انه
هناك اتهامات لا توجد اتهامات القضيه
الاهم بلغ السيل الزب هؤلاء الذين يرتكبوا
هذه الجرائم ضد الشعب الفلسطيني ليسوا بشر
ليسوا بشر ودماء الفلسطينيين ليست اقل
ثمنا واقل قيمه من دماء الاسرائيليين قبل
قليل استشهد عاملين فلسطينيين دهسهما
مستوطن اسرائيلي اخر في حيفا كل يوم في
جريمه جديده الذهاب الى محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه انا اعرف ان له اجراءات لكن
المساله ربما لو كانت الظروف طبيعيه
وعاديه لتدرج تدريجا في في المعاهدات
الدوليه المختلفه حتى محكمه الجنايات لكن
الان الامر اختلف وهذا ما يجب ان يدركه كل
القياديين الفلسطينيين نحن في وضع نوعي
مختلف والانضمام لميثاق ربما ليس معقد
المطلوب ان نتقدم بالطلب ونصبح اعضاء في
هذا الميثاق وبعد ذلك تفتح الابواب لتقديم
اسرائيل للمحاكم هذا بالضبط ما تخشاه
اسرائيل اليوم لكن حتى نصل اليه يجب ان
يكون هناك اد ان مرحله انطوت انتهت
المراهنه على مفاوضات مع اسرائيل الان
مراهنه على شيء عقيم لا مجال لذلك علينا
ان ندرك اننا في مرحله كفاح ولسنا في
مرحله اليه في
البدايه هذا ما اشرت اليه في البدايه عن
المراجعه الاستراتيجيه سيد عبد الله عبد
الله ما هي الخطوات ذات الفعاليه التي
تقوم بها السلطه الفلسطينيه في مواجهه ما
يتعرض له الفلسطينيون حاليا في الضفه
الغربيه وفي القدس
الخطوه الاولى كما قلت لك في الاول على
الصعيد الداخلي الهبه الشعبيه القائمه
والتي تدعو اليها السلطه في المقاومه
الشعبيه منذ سنوات ثم على الصعيد الدولي
هنالك اتصالات مع كل الدول ذات العلاقه
الاعضاء الدائمين الخمسه ب مجلس الامن مع
الاعضاء ذات الوزن على الساحه الدوليه مثل
الهند مثل البرازيل مثل جنوب افريقيا
وغيرها هنالك رساله وجهت اليوم للامين
العام للامم المتحده المطالبه بهيئه تحقيق
دوليه لانه هذا الامر كما قلت لك لا ينحصر
بيننا وبين الاسرائيليين هذا ينحصر على
نازيه جديده على المجتمع الدولي ان يقف
ضدها بنفس الصلابه بنفس القوه اللي واجه
فيها الهولوكوست في قبل 70 عاما ثالثا
هنالك ايضا توجه لدعوه الاطراف الساميه
المتعاقده على اتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه لانه
شعبنا في ظل هذه الهجمه الشرسه التي
تتصاعد ولا تنخفض على المجتمع الدولي ان
ياخذ مسؤوليته لل توفير الحمايه الدوليه
لشعب يقع تحت الاحتلال لدوله اعترف بها
المجتمع الدولي قبل في نوفمبر من عام 2012
هذه الاجراءات كلها سيتبعها اجراءات اخرى
في عديد من الخطوات التي تجري ولكن خلي
يكون في نوع من الثقه نبدا كيف نتعاون
للتقدم الى الا تمام كل الاجراءات اللي
صارت في السابق ايضا كنا نجد من يعترض
عليها في البدايه ولكن عندما تصل الى
نتيجه ايجابيه جميعنا نصفر لها ونريد ان
نبني عليها ونتقدم الى الامام ابقى معي
سيد عبد الله عبد الله وضيوفي ايضا من رام
الله ومن واشنطن فاصل مشاهدينا نناقش بعده
الخطوات التي يمكن ان تتخذها السلطه
لحمايه شعبها ضد انتهاكات الاحتلال
نرجو
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه
لحمايه شعبها من الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
واعود الى ضيفي من واشنطن سعيد عراقات سيد
عريقات في ظل الظروف التي تمر بها المنطقه
هل تعتقد ان بامكان السلطه ان تتراجع عن
الاتفاقات سياسيه كانت ام ام امنيه مع
اسرائيل والذهاب الى ابعد في مواجهه ما
تقوم به
بكل تاكيد علينا ان نراجع ماذا حققت هذه
الاتفاقيات ما الذي
حققته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعتمد على
السلطه الفلسطينيه لتنفيذ برامجه على
الارض بينما هو بينما
يستشر يستشري الاستيطان ويزداد الاستيطان
وما علينا الا ان نراجع الارقام منذ 94
وحتى اليوم لنرى عدد المستوطنات وعدد
المستوطنين الاتفاقات العديده التي دائما
هي متوقع منها ان تنفذ من قبل طرف واحد
وهو الطرف الفلسطيني وهو الطرف العضف ولا
الطرف المحاصر على هذه القياده الفلسطينيه
اي ونحن نستوعب تماما انها قادت الشعب
الفلسطيني في ادق واصعب مراحل النضال
الفلسطيني عليها الان ان ان تلقي نظره
ثاقبه الى ما مارسته خلال ال عاما الماضيه
وان من انطلاقا من هذه النقطه ان تتوجه
الى المحافل الدوليه الى الامم المتحده
وان تصر على كونها او تعمل من اجل ان تصبح
دوله تحت الاحتلال وانهاء قبل كل شيء
انهاء قضيه التنسيق الامني لان التنسيق
الامني يزيد من من شراسه الاحتلال ويعطي
الاحتلال امكانيات يجب ان لا تكون متوفره
له في ملاحقه ابناء شعبنا الذين يناضلون
ضد الاحتلال دكتور الدكتور البرغوتي يعني
عندما تسمع السيد عبد الله عبد الله يتحدث
عن تبني هبه انت هبه شعبيه جديده الا يعني
ذلك بانه ضمنا
مراجعه استراتيجيه لكل فتره المفاوضات
السابقه وبالتالي نحن امام مرحله جديده قد
تكون انتفاضه جديده في مناطق
الضفه نعم ومثل هذه المراجعه مرحب بها
طبعا و انا اعتقد اليوم اننا بحاجه الى
عده خطوات الخطوه الاولى تعزيز وتص صعيد
المقاومه الشعبيه ويجب ان تقدم المؤسسات
الرسميه وخاصه منظمه التحرير كل الدعم
لهذه المقاومه الشعبيه والتي يمكن ان
تتطور الى انتفاضه شعبيه مشابهه للانتفاض
الشعبيه الاولى نحن لا نتحدث عن انتفاضه
مسلحه ولكن نتحدث عن انتفاضه شعبيه بقيم
ومعايير الانتفاضه الشعبيه الاولى عام
1987 وما رايناه في شوارع القدس مظهر
يذكرنا بتلك الانتفاضه بالتالي دعم
المقاومه الشعبيه لكن ايضا هذا يتطلب حتى
يشع الجمهور بالاطمئنان ويشارك بقوه ان
يشعر ان لديه قياده وطنيه موحده وان تتوحد
جميع القوى الفلسطينيه وان تتم يتم انجاز
المصالحه الوطنيه النقطه الثالثه وهي مهمه
جدا يجب اخذ توجه بالمطالبه بعقوبات
ومقاطعه ضد اسرائيل يجب ان يكون الموقف
الفلسطيني الرسمي مشابه للموقف الشعبي دعم
المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات وليس فقط على
المستوطنين والمستوطنات بل على اسرائيل
باعتبارها الراعيه لهذا الارهاب والممارسه
له وهذا ما فعله المؤتمر الوطني الافريقي
في جنوب افريقيا ولولا حركه المقاطعه ضد
نظام الفصل العنصري في جنوب افريقيا لم
انهار نحن نتحدث هنا عن تضافر المقاومه
الشعبيه مع حركه المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات
ضد اسرائيل ومع العلم انه يحق لنا ان
نناضل بكل الاشكال كل الاشكال مسموح لنا
ان نناضل فيها والمقاومه الشعبيه هي احد
هذه
الاشكال الان هناك بمفردها لنتحدث عن كل
خطوه بمفردها سيد عبد الله عبد الله انت
اشرت الى هبه شعبيه تتبناها السلطه لكن هل
تستقيم هبه شعبيه او انتفاضه جديده مع
تنسيق امني مستمر مع الاحتلال من قبل
السلطه لا اسمح لي ما هو كمان ايش فهمنا
للتنسيق الامني يا اخي الكريم ما بصير
احنا ناخذ موضوع ونفسر ك على هوانا
التنسيق الامني الذي يمكن يمشي الان هو ما
فيه مصلحه لاجراء لعملياتنا اللي بتفيد
شعبنا التنسيق الامني مش بمعنى انه احنا
عملاء عند الاسرائيليين تذكر اخي الكريم
انه 40% من اسرانا كانوا هم من رجال الامن
تذكر اخي الكريم انه ثلث شهداء الانتفاضه
الثانيه كانوا من رجال الامن الامن قضيه
مصلحه وطنيه وعقيده وطنيه عندهم مش هذا
الاساس الاساس انا كنت اتمنى انه ايضا ضمن
هذا البرنامج ياتي ليس فقط ما هو المطلوب
من القياده الفلسطينيه والقياده
الفلسطينيه لا تتاخر عن مياتها لانه
الانجازات اللي تمت في السنوات السابقه
يعني ما اجتش عفويه ماجت من السماء هبه
علينا اجت نتيجه جهد جبار مكثف من هذه
القياده التي نتكلم
عنها سيد عب الله اوضح لنا هذه
الضح لنا هذه الكره فيما يتعلق بالتنسيق
الامني لان نقطه هامه جدا اوضح لنا كيف
يمكن ان يكون التنسيق الامني هو لحمايه
الشعب الفلسطيني فقط اوضح لنا عمليا هذه
النقطه ما المقصود بها
يعني انا بقول لك هذا الجانب احنا اذا اذا
لما بعثنا 20 شحنه سياره ادويه الى قطاع
غزه لا يتم ذلك الا بتنسيق
امني معبر كيرم ابو سالم لما بده
يدخلوا السولر الصناعي لا يتم الا بتنسيق
امني اذا واحد مريض بده في حاله طارئه
لازم يروح على مستشفى في داخل اسرائيل لا
يتم الا
ب اذا وزراء بدهم يتنقلوا او مسؤولينا بين
الضفه
وغزه لا هذا اتفاق اخي الكريم اذا بنراجع
احنا الاتفاقات تماما تباغ غزه اريحا في
ار
1994 بفصل هذه مستلزمات من من
ضمنها الرابط بين
غزه والضفه الغربيه
من ضمنها الملاحقه الساخنه من ضمنها
المطلوبين او ارتكاب اي حتى جريمه جنائيه
في احد الجوانب ضمن هذه كلها
ضمن التنسيق الامني لكن خليني انا انا كنت
انا بدي اطرح الفكره التاليه يا اخي
الكريم احنا في هذا الوضع الذي نواجه لا
نواجه اسرائيل وحدها نحن في فتره يعني قبل
اسبوعين في بدايه الاسبوعين قبل يوم
الاربعاء الماضي العالم كله انحاز الى
الجانب الاسرائيلي وبقينا وحدنا نريد من
يقف معنا نريد من يقف من يدعمنا نن عندنا
مشكله مش قادرين ندفع روا الفكره سي سيد
عبد الله سيد عريقات سيدي عريقات وانت انت
استمعت الى سيد عب داعم فع سيد عريقات انت
استمعت الى السيد عبد الله وهو يتحدث عن
امكانيات محدوده
ربما لدى السلطه الفلسطينيه في المواجهه
وبالتالي يجب النظر الى الواقع دون
التنظير اذا صح التعبير بين هلالين على
السلطه الفلسطينيه ما
رايك ليس فقط ماليا على المستوى السياس
صديق عب عب بدنا الاشقاء يكونوا معنا
ودعمونا
تفضل انا اتفق معه في بقضيه انه يجب ان
يكون الاشقاء معنا والعالم معنا واختلف
معه على قضيه انحسار الخيارات الفلسطينيه
لدينا خيارات كثيره علينا ان نتذكر ان
الفلسطينيين هم وحدهم الذين اما ان يعطوا
الشرعيه لاسرائيل او يسحبوا هذه الشرعيه
من اسرائيل هذه الحقيقه نحن لدينا امكانات
هائله علينا ان نستغل هذه الامكانات انا
عندما نقول اننا يجب ان ان ان نبحث وننقض
عن اساليب اخرى لدينا الاساليب العديده
الاخرى خاصه على الساحه الدوليه اولها
يجب الاتجاه بان تكون هناك فلسطين دوله
تحت الاحتلال وليس سلطه وطنيه وكانها دوله
قائمه ولديها سياده وتعمل ت تنسيق امني مع
الاحتلال الذي يفسر التنسيق الامني فقط من
طرف واحد قد يكون هناك نوايا حسنه من قبل
السلطه الفلسطينيه بشان التنسيق الامني
لكن عمليا كيف يتم ممارسته على الارض يتم
ممارسته على الارض انه عندما يحدث شيء يحق
للجيش الاسرائيلي ان ياتي وبمساعده قوى
الامن الفلسطينيه ويذهب الى رام الله
ويذهب الى المخيمات في حين هل راينا حاله
واحده من الامن الفلسطيني يلاحق
المستوطنين الذين يرتكبون الجرائم هذا هو
هو الذي يجب اعاده النظر فيه ط ابقى معي
ايضا سيد عريقات الكتور البرغوثي بدقيقه
واحده فقط هل من فرص قضيع على السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه في هذه
المرحله انا اعتقد انه فرص كثيره ستضيع
على الشعب الفلسطيني اذا لم يتم المبادره
لتبني استراتيجيه جديده ومختلفه واريد هنا
ان انبه الى نقطه مهمه يجري تجاهلها وهي
الهبه الشعبيه الرائعه لابناء شعبنا في
الداخل في ارضي 48 وانا احم اليوم على هذه
الهبه الشعبيه اسنادا لاخوتهم واهلهم
ودفاعا عن نفسهم ايضا في وجه نظام عنصري
يمس الفلسطينيين ليس فق في الاراضي
المحتله بل في داخل اراضي 48 ايضا وانا
ايضا احي الان المبادره التي تجري وادعو
وارجوك ان تسمح لي ان ادعو كل الاخوه
العرب في كل العالم العربي وكل الاخوه
المتضامنين معنا في كل العالم ان يتشاركوا
معنا في الحمله التي ستجري في التاسع من
تموز اين بعد اي بعد ثلاث ايام في ذكرى
صدور قرار محكمه هاي ضد الاستيطان والجدار
التي ستكون مظاهرات تضامن مع الاطفال
الفلسطينيين وتضامن مع الشعب الفلسطيني في
كل العالم يجري الدعوه لها الان وهي ستكون
مظهر من مظاهر القدره على حشد كل القوى
الخارجيه الى جانب الشعب الفلسطيني وكل
قوى التضامن كما جرى مع نضالات شعبيه اخرى
نقطه اخيره بالنسبه للتنسيق الامني انا
انا استغرب وان الاوان ان يوضع حد لهذه
الظاهره ان يطالب شعب تحت الاحتلال بان
يوفر الامن للذين يحتلون ولمستو الذين
يسرقوا ارضه وهو عاجز عن حمايه شعبه اشكرك
جزيلا دكتور مصطفى البوفي الامين العام
اشكرك جزيلا الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه واشكر ايضا عبد الله
عبد الله رئيس اللجنه السياسيه في المجلس
التشريع الفلسطيني ومن واشنطن الكاتب او
الكاتب الصحفي سعيد عريق شكرا جزيلا لكم
وبهذا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر
جديد